>>> WE WILL HAVE A
RECONCILIATION BILL.
THAT IS FOR SURE.
>> IT IS NOT SOME MAJOR
CATACLISM IF THERE ISN'T A VOTE
TODAY.
MARK MY WORDS, THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL WILL BE
PASSED AND A VERSION OF THE
RECONCILIATION BILL WILL BE AS
WELL.
>> WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO VOTE
FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
UNTIL THE RECONCILIATION BILL
HAS PASSED.
SO WE'RE IN THE SAME PLACE.
>> SHAME FOR THAT.
NO TWO BILLS SHOULD EVER BE
LINKED TOGETHER.
>> Bret: SENATOR JOE MANCHIN
THERE.
AT THIS HOUR WE ARE TOLD THE
HOUSE WILL NOT HAVE ANY VOTES
BEFORE 9 P.M.
WE DON'T KNOW THE STATUS OF
WHETHER THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
IS COMING UP.
WHETHER THERE'S A DEAL ON THE
RECONCILIATION BILL.
WE DO KNOW THIS.
JOE MANCHIN LAID DOWN A MARKER
TODAY.
PEOPLE TOOK NOTE SAYING JOE
MANCHIN DELIVERS A DAGGER TO THE
HEART OF THE PROGRESSIVE CAUSE.
THEY CAN HUFF AND PUFF IF THEY
WANT BUT WON'T BLOW DOWN THE
WEST VIRGINIA'S HOUSE.
RE-ENGINEERING THE FABRIC OF
AMERICAN LIFE A MODERN
PROGRESSISM'S FULL POINT.
CRISIS DEMAND IMMEDIATELY AND
WIDE RANGING ACTION NOT
INCREMENTAL CHANGE OR TINKERING
AROUND THE EDGES.
THEIR AMBITIONS CAN ONLY PREVAIL
IN A DEMOCRACY IF THEY ARE
SUPPORTED BY PUBLIC OPINION.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE AT THIS
HOUR.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL.
PUBLISHER OF FEDERALIST,
NATIONAL POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT
OF NATIONAL PUBLIC RADIO AND
TREY GOWDY, FORMER CONGRESSMAN
FROM SOUTH CAROLINA.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THIS IS
GOING.
WE DO KNOW THAT IT'S GOING TO BE
LESS THAN $3.5 TRILLION AND THE
RECONCILIATION BILL, IF IT
HAPPENS.
>> YES.
IT'S DEFINITELY GOING TO BE
LESS.
WE'VE KNOWN THAT FOR QUITE
SOMETIME.
WE DIDN'T KNOW THE ACTUAL
PARAMETERS OF THE NEGOTIATION.
I THINK THE BIG PROGRESS THAT
WAS MADE TODAY IS THAT JOE
MANCHIN SAID IN PUBLIC BEFORE A
CAMERA WHAT HE'S BEEN SAYING IN
PRIVATE AND ACTUALLY ON PAPER IN
THIS MEMO THAT HE AND CHUCK
SHUMER SIGNED, THAT HIS NUMBER,
TOP LINE NUMBER IS $1.5
TRILLION.
HE HAS SOME OTHER SUBSTANTIVE
DEMANDS.
SPECIAL SAFETY NET PROGRAMS TO
BE TESTED.
HE WANTS TO ROLL BACK THE TRUMP
TACK CUTS INCLUDING CARRIED
INTEREST.
HE HAS A WHOLE LOT OF THINGS
THAT HE CARES ABOUT.
NOW, HE DID NOT SAY THAT THIS
WAS A HARD AND FAST NUMBER AND
HE WASN'T FLEXIBLE AT ALL.
HE SAID, YOU KNOW, WE'RE GOING
TO NEGOTIATE.
SO, SOMEWHERE BETWEEN $3.5
TRILLION AND $1.5 TRILLION IS
WHERE THEY'LL END UP, IF THEY
CAN GET A DEAL AMONG THEMSELVES.
>> Bret: THAT'S A BIG IF, TREY.
SAYING WE'RE GOING TO VOTE
AGAINST THIS INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
IF WE DON'T HAVE A DEAL, A VOTE
ON RECONCILIATION.
>> YEAH, BRET.
I GIVE CREDIT TO THE
PROGRESSIVES IN THE HOUSE.
THEY WATCHED VERY CAREFULLY AS
THE FREEDOM CAUCUS ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE PROVED YOU CAN
GET A LOT MORE FAMOUS OPPOSING
YOUR OWN LEADERSHIP INSTEAD
FIGHTING WITH THE OTHER SIDE.
FAME HAS BECOME THE ULTIMATE
POLITICAL VIRTUE.
I WILL SAY THIS.
JEN PSAKI USED THE WORD
DEMOCRACY.
LET'S LAY ASIDE THE FACT THAT
THEY TRIED TO RAM IT THROUGH
WITH A PARLIAMENTARIAN AND GIVE
IT ALL IN ONE BILL.
YOU AND I WON THE SAME NUMBER OF
COUNTIES IN WEST VIRGINIA THAT
JOE BIDEN DID.
ARIZONA WAS LESS THAN ONE HALF
OF A PERCENTAGE POINT.
SO DON'T BE LECTURING JOE
MANCHIN AN
BOUT DEM.
>> Reporter: JEN PSAKI WAS ASKED
ABOUT THE WHITE HOUSE LOSING ALL
CONTROL OF THIS.
>> THIS IS HOW DEMOCRACY WORKS.
I KNOW IT FEELS FOREIGN BECAUSE
THERE WASSEN MUCH THAT HAPPENED
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
BUT HOW IT WORKS IS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ELECT THEIR ELECTED
OFFICIALS, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, PUTS FORWARD A
BOLD AND AMBITIOUS PROPOSAL AND
EVERYBODY NEGOTIATES ABOUT IT.
THEY HAVE DIFFERENT POINTS OF
VIEW.
THAT'S HOW DEMOCRACY SHOULD
WORK.
WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF IT.
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO PAINT OVER
HOW MESSY IT LOOKS FROM THE
OUTSIDE.
WE KNOW THAT.
>> Bret: BEN?
>> WELL, WE'RE NOT ACTUALLY A
DEMOCRACY, JUST TO POINT THAT
OUT.
IF WE WERE, THEN WE WOULD BE
FINE WITH MAJORITIES RUNNING
TOWARD ALL THESE TYPES OF
EXTREME STEPS, EVEN IF THEY WERE
SLIMMEST OF MAJORITIES.
THERE'S AN IMPORTANT REASON AND
THE FOUNDERS REALLY BELIEVED IN
IT, THAT WE ARE NOT THAT WAY AND
OUR GOVERNMENT DOES NOT WORK
THAT WAY.
THAT'S WHY JOE MANCHIN IS SO
IMPORTANT IN THIS MOMENT.
LOOK, HE READS THE POLITICS VERY
WELL.
NOT JUST IN HIS OWN STATE, BUT I
THINK IN THE BROADER DYNAMIC.
I THINK IN THIS MOMENT THERE
OUGHT TO BE A LOT OF CRITIQUES
OF THE APPROACH THAT NANCY
PELOSI USED.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, SHE MAY
HAVE MISSED AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ACHIEVE A PACKAGE THAT COULD BE
MUCH MORE PERHAPS THAN WHAT
MANCHIN'S NUMBER WOULD BE, BUT
FAR LESS THAN WHAT PROGRESSIVES
ARE CURRENTLY DEMANDING.
TAKING THE STEP THAT SHE DID, IN
TERMS OF LINKING THESE MEASURES
TOGETHER IN THE WAY THAT HE DID
--
>> Bret: WE ALWAYS KNEW SENATOR
MANCHIN WAS GOING TO BE CRUCIAL.
WE TALKED TO HIM ON THIS SHOW
MANY TIMES AND ASKED HIM
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS.
TODAY, MARA, YOU'RE RIGHT.
$1.5 TRILLION TOP LINE THAT HE
TALKED ABOUT.
TAKE A LISTEN TO THIS AND
REACTION ON THE PROGRESSIVE
SIDE.
>> ELECT MORE LIBERALS.
I'M NOT ASKING THEM TO CHANGE.
I'M WILLING TO COME FROM ZERO
UP.
>> I BELIEVE IN MY HEART THAT
WHAT WE CAN DO AND WHAT WE NEED
TO ADDRESS RIGHT NOW WITHOUT
BASICALLY CHANGING OUR WHOLE
SOCIETY TO AN ENTITLEMENT
MENTALITY.
>> WHICH SENATOR ARE WE
NEGOTIATING WITH?
IS IT JUNE MANCHIN, SEPTEMBER
MANCHIN, AUGUST MANCHIN?
WILL DECEMBER MANCHIN BE
DIFFERENT?
>> IT'S ACTUALLY JULY 28TH
MANCHIN.
THAT'S THE DATE OF THE MEMO.
>> Bret: THAT'S RIGHT.
>> IT HASN'T CHANGED SINCE THEN.
LOOK.
WHAT HE SAID WAS BASIC FACTS.
THE REASON DEMOCRATS ARE IN THIS
FIX IS BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
GIGANTIC AGENDA AND MINISCULE
MAJORITY.
THEY FAILED TO WIN THE SEATS
THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE GOING TO
WIN IN 2020.
AS JOE MANCHIN SAID TODAY, I
HAVE NEVER BEEN A LIBERAL.
HE'S REPRESENTING A STATE THAT
TRUMP WON BY, WHAT, 29 POINTS?
LIKE THAT SONG IN HAMILTON, THEY
DON'T HAVE THE VOTES AND THEY'RE
GONNA HAVE TO COMPROMISE.
THAT'S JUST THE WAY IT IS.
>> Reporter: TREY, YOU'VE SEEN
THIS PLAY BEFORE.
SPEAKER PELOSI HAS PULLED
RABBITS OUT OF HATS
LEGISLATIVELY BEFORE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GONNA
HAPPEN TONIGHT.
DO YOU THINK SHE COULD COBBLE
THIS TOGETHER?
>> IT DEPEND.
IT DEPENDS ON HOW MANY
REPUBLICAN SENATORS CONTINUE TO
CALL REPUBLICAN MEMBERS OF THE
HOUSE AND ASK THEM TO VOTE FOR
THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
KEVIN MCCARTHY HAS A JOB TO DO
HERE, TOO, WHICH IS SKAOEP THE
REPUBLICANS COALESCED.
I LOVE AOC'S POLITICAL STRATEGY
WHICH IS INSULT THE PERSON WHOSE
VOTE YOU NEED.
I JUST DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
WORK.
>> Bret: LET'S TAKE YOU TO THE
FLIP SIDE.
WHAT ABOUT THOSE MODERATE
REPUBLICANS WHO LOOK AT THE $1.2
TRILLION INFRASTRUCTURE BILL AND
SAY, THIS IS A CHANCE TO FINALLY
BUILD THAT BRIDGE, TO FINALLY
FIX THAT ROAD THAT I HAVE BEEN
TALK ABOUT FIXING TO MY
CONSTITUENTS FOREVER.
MAYBE I SHOULD VOTE FOR IT.
IS THE POLITICS OF THE MOMENT
MORE IMPORTANT THAN THE BRIDGE
AT HOME?
>> I THINK THAT'S THE BIG
QUESTION, BUT HEADED INTO A
MIDTERM YEAR, DELIVERY OF THAT
BRIDGE IS GOING TO BECOME LESS
AND LESS OF THEIR PRIORITY.
ONE MORE NOTE ON THIS.
THE KIND OF JABS THAT WE'VE SEEN
NOT JUST AT JOE MANCHIN BUT
TODAY FROM SOME PROGRESSIVES HAS
BECOME MORE AND MORE AGGRESSIVE.
THE IDEA SAID BY ONE MEMBER
TODAY THAT SHE HASN'T SHOWN US
ANYTHING BUT A DESIGNER PURSE.
THAT'S NOT THE KIND OF INSULT
THAT'S GOING TO GO ACROSS WITH
SOMEONE NAVIGATING A SITUATION
AND WHO LAST I CHECKED HAS 40%
POPULARITY AMONG REPUBLICANS IN
ARIZONA.
>> Bret: AND EITHER ONE OF THEM
COULD BECOM